you look beautiful babe thank you babe
barque got me this Crown when I walked
in you deserve
it I agree the birthday girl I kind of
got tued into doing a big party my usual
Vibe for every birthday is Disneyland or
going on a trip so that I'm out of town
and I went to Santa Barbara with Travis
that was like all I needed I was like
I'm done hey happy birthday how are you
Hi how are you how are you I birthday
girl Crown thank you I love you I I'm
like over it already it was fun but I'm
never going to have a birthday party
again because I get it like I know I
didn't even Bowl I didn't play one
arcade game it's like hosting things at
your house that's what it's like you
just have to stand there and say hi to
everyone it's like draining